we are joined now by republican senator
tim scott of south carolina he is here
because he's the author of a new book
it's called america a redemption story
uh senator good morning thank you the
book right here uh it's a good read i
think it's going to connect with a lot
of people it's got two chapters on the
former president president trump you
clearly have a good relationship with
him he's very nice to your mom yes uh
but we're at this extraordinary moment
in american history where that former
president is the subject of multiple
investigations and his home was searched
by the fbi overnight so i have to put
the question to you do you still feel
that he is the best representative of
the republican party he certainly is the
largest voice in american politics
period republican or democrat vilsack
he'll continue to be the more focus you
put on him the more likely the
supporters will rally around him
there is a huge divide in our country
but wait a second before you go senator
that wasn't the question he said largest
which is
well i mean
the good news is i get to answer the
question how i see that question but the
truth is that he is without any question
the most powerful voice in in all of
politics and that's why so many people
left and right continue to focus
on president trump yeah but why this is
such a dangerous moment in our history
and a lot of people pointed this out is
because we are divided
there are the wings of our government
that are supposed to be nonpartisan but
now seem to be politicized and one of
those wings is the fbi so
do you think the fbi do you still
believe and trust in the fbi to do its
job even with a former president uh in a
non-partisan way or do you believe as
the as the former president says the fbi
is executing a witch hunt well we've had
the we've had the fbi before
uh the judiciary committee just in the
last two weeks trying to figure out why
they do what they do and there's been
lots of questions before this raid about
whether or not the fbi is doing their
job
apolitical and we don't know the answer
to that question yet this is
about the fbi this is going to raise
more questions in my opinion we need to
let this play out and see exactly what
happens but we should all have been
stunned and surprised and shocked at
what happened yesterday the real
question is hey what is the federal
federal
records act and and b what are we
talking about it had it has to be
something of incredible magnitude for at
least my side of the owl to say that was
that was warranted without that i think
we're going to find ourselves in a
very big
mess as it relates to the credibility
of the fbi so you don't have any concern
that they're going to find anything at
the mar-a-lago i think we should really
as opposed to rushing the judgment the
most important thing that we can do is
let it play out because i have no idea
what they were looking for i don't think
anybody knows what they were at that
point i think i think it's interesting
that as you sit before us today you are
not saying the former president trump is
the best
representative of the republican party
and you're also not saying don't worry
america you can trust the fbi well i
think that i am saying that i love my
new book
conversation
fbi director chris ray was appointed by
uh donald trump we should point that out
too but in your book you say when it
comes to president trump rather than try
to soften his hard edges you found it
best to learn to utilize them and on
january 6 you said it was a tragic day a
culmination of individuals making bad
choices you do not hold donald trump in
the book anyway accountable for what
happened january 6. well gail one of the
reasons why your
your viewers would want to buy the book
is to get that behind the scenes view of
what actually happened at the capitol as
opposed to just hearing the media's
account for it which
most were not inside the united states
capital i was we could walk through how
it feels to be hunted you walk through
rolling your sleeves up taking your tie
off and literally asking yourself what
weapon can i find to defend myself until
i die yeah you talked about it i had a
pain in my hand absolutely talked about
actually calming everybody down and say
look everybody let's let's just take a
second but i want to go back to donald
trump's role in it for just a second he
has taken no uh responsibility for it
and january 6 you heard from rioters who
said look we went because he asked us to
we were there because he called us there
doesn't the president have don't his
words have power and shouldn't he be
more careful with his words yes he was
encouraging people that he knew were
armed well i i don't know that anyone
knows
that the crowd was armed when they uh
called to come to the capitol
was was put out there number one number
two i would say this though
every person
has the responsibility
of taking fully the decisions that they
make and be responsible for those
decisions
i think giving that to anybody other
than the individual
is giving the individual a pass but
president have responsibility to senator
of course of course of course some would
say the most responsibility i would say
that we all have the most responsibility
for our own words this is easy uh for us
to put the blame on someone else right
but
as the guy that felt hunted in the
moment and
watching my watching my senate
colleagues
look for a route to escape one of the
things you'll see in the book is how
important it is in the middle of a
chaotic situation to find peace clarity
and then be decisive in going back out
that same way you sounded terrifying can
i vision can i talk about chapter five
in the book because the headline is tim
scott for president oh
oh he's he's getting ready to tell us
something tim scott for president the
beginning of chapter five right
um and then you go on to say it's for
president of your high school
tim scott for president tim scott for
friends uh then you go on to talk about
it was a campaign that you ran but it
does raise a question many people think
when you're writing a book like this yes
it's because you are
thinking about running for president
certainly reads that way and your
publisher apparently thought he had all
these guys running for president because
they wrote it in the front of the book
in a message so talk to him
break it down let me break it out right
here for you breaking news please listen
carefully okay we're listening if you're
gonna run for president you don't say in
your butt according to my publishers
2022. that's right they didn't make a
typo i failed civics but even i got that
part right there's no presidential
election in 2022. there is however a
re-election campaign in 2022 and i am a
part of that so i'm looking forward to
representing the people of south
carolina for hopefully the next six
years i know and you love south carolina
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah we all understand that
but but
uh
what would it take for you to consider a
run for president do you think you would
bring something to the table that maybe
other candidates don't have at this
point i certainly believe that my best
objective today is to make sure that i'm
as successful as possible in my
re-election and as a part of my
re-election strategy it is to make sure
that the voters and the constituents of
south carolina whether you vote for me
or not see me as your united states
senator ultimately you should not worry
about what's next if you haven't
finished what's now right right now this
book is titled america a redemption
story yes sir this is a great country
but we've had some dark times absolutely
where are we in our redemption journey
as a country yeah thank god we're
on the right path in the last 50 years
have been the best 50 years in this
america america's history think about
the fact that we've suffered through a
civil war we had the jim crow south my
grandfather was born in 1921 and i talk
a lot about his journey in the book we
also had the 1960s we had the challenges
in the 70s we had rodney king in the 90s
comparatively speaking we are in a far
better position than we have been we are
not finished yet with the journey there
is a long way to go to do without any
question but listen we are also
celebrating the fact that
three out of four on this stage right
now are of african americans we're
talking about the fact that we've had a
african-american president
african-american vice president we've
had a chief of staff who was an
african-american we've had more success
in the last 50 years than we had the
first 190 combined and so we should
continue to focus on what needs to be
done while celebrating what has been
done what we've already accomplished
that point out the american dream is
never realized overnight not an event
but a way of life one of the many good
lines in this book uh senator scott
thank you very much for being here the
book is america a redemption story and
it is on sale right choosing hope
creating unity yes yes there's two
there's two subtitles
presidential thank you very much